hi I think it's super important that we
differentiate between abolishing
defunding and reforming the police
regardless of which action you support
let's just start by saying what we mean
and not conflating ideas to make it more
palatable for people the starter reform
by and large most people would agree
that the criminal justice arraignment is
not perfect police reform looks to
specifically introduce positive change
to police conduct with things like more
training new technologies so body cams
and community policing the ideology
behind police reform is that while the
system isn't perfect with enough focus
and care we can limit the ability of
police officers to abuse their power or
endanger the lives of the people they're
supposed to protect now this is
different than the cost of the fun
police because reforms are ultimately
going to cost more money incentivizing a
larger budget for the police department
whereas defunding the police calls for
lowering the budget and reallocating
those funds to support community health
and public services those who wanted to
fund the police believe that the more
money police have the more dangerous
they become which we can see in the way
that many departments around the nation
have become militarized without me or
how having more money to get more cops
results in over policing in poor
neighborhoods where performance allocate
focus and care to the police departments
those who wanted to fund the police
shift that focus and care to the
community itself hopefully lowering the
need for police intervention and
subsequently lowering opportunities for
any abuse of power both of our current
presidential prospects oppose the idea
of defunding the police but the movement
is found more traction amongst local
governments now where the funding and
abolishing the police part ways is in
their endgame most abolitionists would
agree that the police should be defunded
but only as a means to an end not as the
end in itself abolishing the police
means rejecting the idea that the police
department can be altered or reformed in
any meaningful way even with a slash to
the budget make sure you check out the
work of organizations like critical
resistance
we're cleaning the block to learn more
about what abolitionists call reformist
reforms or reforms that constantly need
to be revisited and reformed later on
but before we talk about the
complexities of abolition we need to
first acknowledge that this is not a new
conversation for many of us the
abolition movement is only on our radar
due to the current national spotlight on
state Saints and killings of black
people by police but people beyond this
moment specifically black women have
been pointing us towards the goals of
that listen for decades scholars and
educators like Mario cava Ruth Wilson
Gilmore Mark Lamont Hill Angela Davis
these are all people we should be
listening to following learning from if
we're new to the idea or if we have
questions but when we paint this as
something new then we create room for
people to dismiss the entire movement as
Nighy abolitionists believed that we
should be focused on creating the
conditions in which police are not
needed in our society at all not on not
one of them and creating those
conditions involves something I like to
call the three beans first D is the fun
which we've already talked about as the
vesting from police and investing in
community driven programs that promote
health and safety then we've got
decentralized which means redistributing
the functions and responsibilities of
the police to groups that are
specifically trained in those areas
currently the police are expected to
meet way too many public needs from
traffic stops to welfare checks to in
the case of George Floyd the suspected
use of counterfeit bills even the
response to violent crimes can be the
responsibility of a much smaller
specialized force the third D is to
criminalize lowering the bar for what's
considered a criminal offense things
like sex work drug use homelessness or
vagrancy are criminal offenses that
aren't inherently violent or unsafe and
with proper support and regulation can
function without police
intervention that's just a few of the
ways that abolitionists work to create
the conditions that we need the things
like the car serration and restorative
justice that also plays a huge part and
what it means to be an abolitionist but
none of those steps or deeds should be
mistaken for abolition itself the goal
of abolition is exactly as its takes to
abolish the police and if we're not
clear on that goal we can't ever get
there and if we're not as clear as
possible about what we're doing we run
the risk of maybe dismantling and
disbanding some police departments but
then creating a system that's just as
harmful or recreating police departments
under a different name and happened with
the Thirteenth Amendment of slavery and
it gonna happen again today we also have
to abolish the idea that the police
exists to protect us we've watched one
too many cop shows and have created this
collective mythos about who the police
are and how they function in our society
we've had this trope about a few bad
apples and drilled into our minds so now
whenever the institution is challenged
we can't help but retreat and protect
the individuals that are associated with
it for abolition movements across
history the biggest barrier has always
been a lack of imagination some of us
though have never had these illusions or
have them dispel really early through
consistent interactions with an
institution with police that sought to
brutalize violated scapegoat our
communities but what else is to be
expected from an organization that finds
its origin in the early 1700s as slave
patrol later evolving into segregation
enforcement and keeping freed slaves in
chat police have always existed to
protect property over people they've
always protected each other over the
communities that they were there to
serve at this point we're done with them
failing us so if you're an abolitionist
say it proudly don't water down the
movement to a piece of the sensibilities
of
understand and if you're not an
abolitionist and you identify more with
defunding or performing the police say
what your chest
stop co-opting abolition when you're not
actually about that life that doesn't
disservice to everyone the clear we are
the easier it is to move forward
[Music]